NITIN MOTGI: Hello everyone,
and welcome to Building Data
Lake on GCP Talk.
My name is Nitin Motgi.
I'm a group product manager
in the data analytics group.
So today we we've
only be talking
about how you build data
lakes, but let us first
understand what a data lake is.
Data lake is a centralized
and a secure data platform
for ingesting, storing,
processing, and analyzing
all your data structured,
semi-structured,
and unstructured data at scale.
When we work with
our customers we
find out that the traditional
approach to building data
lakes, when you bring data
from various different sources
and land them into one single
central store, has not worked,
and has not provided
good results.
And they have also
told us that they
would like to have more
use case-driven data lakes.
So the traditional
approach basically
ended up creating,
instead of lakes,
it ended up creating swamps.
And too much of
operational cost was
incurred during the
maintaining of those lakes.
But when you look at what
those data lakes are,
and what is the value
proposition of having a data
lake, there are many.
One of them, to begin
with, is cost savings.
You save a lot of
operational and capital cost
in essentially doing all of
these transformations outside
of your traditional
data warehouse.
It also increases the
quality of the data.
As the data actually gets
processed in the lake,
the quality of the data as
it progresses to the lake
increases dramatically.
Now, if you build
a good data lake,
it has to have a fast
discovery mechanism which
will allow you to
identify all kinds of data
that exists within the lake.
And then, when you think about
what actually this data lake is
going to provide
for you, it's going
to reduce the time
from analytics.
It's going to basically make
it easier for doing analytics
that you haven't been
able to do it before.
And with having better
analytic explanations,
you're able to get
to market faster.
Now, there are very
different components
that are involved
in building a lake.
Whether it is you're
doing a data discovery,
you're organizing your data,
you're doing transformations,
you're doing
optimizations, there
are various different
components that
have to be included together
to build the best data lake.
Now, let's see what are some of
the challenges that are there
in building the idea of
a data lake solution.
Data lakes are complex
and time consuming,
The process of building
them and managing
them is extremely difficult.
And the reasons for these things
to be difficult
is because you are
doing a lot of various different
operations within the lake.
First of them that
you begin with
is importing and ingesting data.
It's a very laborious process.
You have to first identify all
of the various different data
sources that exist,
within your organization,
which could be of various
different formats,
and various different
data sources,
that you would have to bring
all that data together using
some form of an injection tool.
Now, once you land
the data in the lake,
you have to organize it.
And if you can't
organize it very well,
it just turns out into a swamp.
So you have to spend
huge amounts of time
organizing the data in the lake.
So it is basically,
you categorize the data
in various segments.
You basically store
them, separate them,
segregate them, and also assign
different security policies
for them.
The next thing that
is particularly
important in the lake
is data transformations.
The data transformation
provides the standardized way
of transforming the
data from a raw form
to a standardized form, and
then actually preparing them
for analytics.
Now combining all of
these things together,
the most important
part that will
bringing all of the
[INAUDIBLE] of a data lake
is the discovery.
If there exists no good
discovery mechanism
in a lake, the data
itself is lost.
And it does incur dark data,
and more such dark data actually
leads to creating a swamp,
rather than a lake that you
would like to have.
And the data quality
aspect of a data lake
is critically important
for a few reasons.
One, if you look
at traditionally
why data lakes were
built, data lakes
were originally built to
offer a lot of the work that
was happening within
the data warehouse
so that they could use the CPU
cycles of the data warehouse
to run the queries.
So when you bring
all of that data
in, and combine that with all
of the structured, unstructured,
and semi-structured
data put together,
you have to have a very
cohesive strategy for ensuring
the quality of the
data as it progresses
through the data lake towards
the data warehouse or data
model.
So there has to be tools that
have to be integrated in order
to have guaranteed data
quality for the data moving
through the data lake.
The last, but not the
least, you want the lake,
but you don't want
a lake that is not
accessible from various
different groups.
Whether they are
open-source tools,
whether they are proprietary
tools, it doesn't matter.
The lake has to be accessible
to all kinds of tools that
exist within the ecosystem.
So interoperability
plays a very vital role
in ensuring that your data
lakes are not isolated,
but they're integrated
into all of the ecosystems.
So lakes can be simple.
There are three primary
pillars on which the lakes can
be built. One, ability to
quickly build the lakes, which
is essentially,
involving populating data
from various different
sources into the lake.
Once you bring the
data into the lake,
you'll need to be able
to catalog that data.
You need to be able
to discover that.
You need to make it easy to
find all of the data that exists
in the lake, So you would have
to have some kind of an ability
to crawl all of that metadata
that exists within the lake,
and store that into
a central repository.
Once the data is
cataloged, it then
has to be indexed so that it's
easily discoverable to a search
mechanism.
And there are many
aspects of it.
The metadata can include a lot
of different types of metadata
that you can integrate.
One is the file format.
The other would be various
different metadata associated
with it, the size of it, the
time, the date it was updated.
So all the different metadata
associated with the data
can be aggregated
with this category.
The next is standardize
and cleansing
the data So as the
data lands in the lake,
the data has to be cleansed,
it has to be turned into--
it has to be
standardized, and it
has to be canonicalize
to conform
to a standard format
that is appropriate
for the organization.
Things like SSM, things
like phone numbers, things
like zip codes--
all these have to be processed
in a standard fashion.
And they have to be
made easy to do that.
So all these transformations
takes a large amount of time.
So these things have
to be simplified
as part of the process.
So you wouldn't want to have
some kind of a code-free tool
that will allow you to do that.
Now that you have brought
the data into the lake,
the first thing you want
to do is secure that data.
You want to be able to
define access control.
And you also want to
normally just do it
on the data, but also the
applications that are going
to be accessing that data.
It's critically important.
Data access control
is one aspect of it,
but the applications that are
going to be accessing the data
also have to be controlled in
terms of who, basically, has
the permissions to run the jobs
that are inevitability going
to be accessing that data.
Now, in the lake, there
are so many different jobs
that are run--
jobs that are
ingesting the data,
standardizing it, jobs
that are transforming it and
preparing it for analytics,
preparing it for warehouses.
Now all of this,
in an enterprise,
are based on a scheduled
time window during which
these jobs have to be executed.
So in order to get a better
insight into those metrics,
you would have to have
ability to understand
all of the different
metrics that are there.
You would have to
have access to them,
as well as being able to look
at the end-to-end assembly
of the jobs that are
all needed in the lake.
Some kind of a dashboard, like
a data operations dashboard,
is required to enable these.
Now because the lake is
a central place where
critical data exists,
and, as you all know,
of all the data that is in
the lake, 20% of the data
is actually very critical.
And it's being used by
a lot of different parts
of the organization.
So, in order to ensure
good security mechanism
and compliance
mechanism, there needs
to exist error logs that
an administrator can
use to see and improve the
access control as well as
the security for the data lake.
Now once you have
ingested the data
and you are provided
the standardization
tools to essentially
transform the data,
and you have secured
it, the next thing
which is critically
important for the lake,
is to make the lake accessible.
Like the lake,
today, if it is not
accessible to the world,
or the pools outside,
people will not find
the lake usable.
So first of all,
the lake should be
able to expose all
of the data that it
has in various different tools.
Whether you're using Spark,
whether you are using Hive,
whether you are using PRESTO,
or you are using BigQuery,
it doesn't matter.
The data that sits
in the lake has
to be immediately
accessible to proprietary,
as well as open source tools.
In addition to that, the data
has to be smartly partitioned.
Because what ends
up happening is,
as there are various
different tools
and various different needs from
an optimization perspective,
the data has to be
partitioned in such a way
that it is integrate
seamlessly with all
of these different tools.
And that is, from an
analytics improvement,
there needs to be handling of
partitioning of the data which
actually is critical.
Then, at the end
of it, you would
have to have standard
ways of moving data
from various different areas
within-- we can call them
zones-- various different
zones within the lake
that you define.
There needs to be a standardized
way of my moving that data.
Because, in some
cases, you might
want to move the data
from the defined zone
directly into your
data warehouse.
So you're having that
ability which is [INAUDIBLE],,
and allowing you to connect
with the world outside
is extremely critical for
making the lake successful.
With these three
simple pillars, you
can build an end-to-end lake.
Now, there are many use
cases that can use this lake.
And let's briefly look
at the kinds of use cases
that we have seen
with our customers,
and how they're actually
using all of the GCP products
and bringing them
together in the use cases.
Let's start with
a simple use case.
First of all, data
warehouse staging.
And this was the primary purpose
for which data lakes were
built. They wanted
to offload all
of the additional ELT,
the transformation that
happens in the warehouse.
They wanted to
offload it in the lake
so that it provides a
lot of cost savings.
And then they have more cost
[INAUDIBLE] in the warehouse
to run analytical queries.
Now, when you bring
that into the lake, what
needs to be
happening is the lake
has to define these
zones or staging areas,
So there are different staging
areas that have to be defined.
So our customers end up defining
various different staging areas
where the data moves from.
They bring all of raw data
from external systems,
whether it is structured,
semi-structured,
or unstructured data
into a raw stage.
Then, they will transform it,
cleanse it, standardize it,
canonicalize it, and move
it into a refine stage.
Now, once the data
is in a refine stage,
they will run further analysis.
They'll apply business rules.
They will, again,
further cleanse the data
based on the business
rules that they
have from their organization.
And then they move it
into a curated stage,
then ending up into
the data warehouse.
So this is a very simple use
case, most common use case
that we see on GCP right now.
Let's look at to the next
one, which is data lakes
are used from the perspective
of data science experimentation.
So it follows a similar model,
but here, the curated data now
has to be accessible
to exploratory tools.
Things like you want to
provide access to notebooks,
you want to provide
access to any
of the other machine-learning
tools that exists.
You want to have
access from the spout.
All the data that is
actually in curated zone
has to be made accessible to all
of these different tools that
exist within open source.
And there are more that keeps
on getting added year over year.
So this is the second
use case that we commonly
see on how people are
using data lakes on GCP.
The last one is an
interesting use case.
And this is recently
becoming more popular
where customers
are using the data,
and transforming it, and
moving it into data warehouse,
but also they're
looking at ways where
they can take the data
from a data warehouse,
and put it back into the lake.
And then have a
federated way of querying
the data between the data
warehouse and the data lake,
have a federated
query capability
that allows you to bring the
data, stale data or old data,
and the new data,
combined together
when you are essentially
doing ad hoc analysis
that you are looking to do.
All of these three use
cases, primarily what
we see with our
customers on GCP.
Now, when you look at what goes
in building these three use
cases, these are the components
of GCP that makes them happen.
Right now, we have various
different services,
and these services have
to be brought together.
And this is something that we
will be looking in the future.
But these are some of
the things that you
would have to bring together
in order to build your lake.
So right now it's
do-it-yourself lake.
And this is going to be--
we are looking at how
we will be integrating
these various
different components
to make it easier for you.
But in order to
build a lake, there
are two main things that you
need from a lake perspective.
First is you need
the central storage.
You need to have the
ability to store the data,
whether it's structured,
semi-structured,
or unstructured data, you need
to have a way to store that.
And part of GCP, there are two
services that are available.
One is Google Could
storage, and the other
is a BigQuery storage.
And we look at what of
those difference are,
and when you should be
using one or the other.
I mean, it's an
easy choice, but I
would like to give you
more information on that
a little bit later.
So storage plays a vital role.
The second one is security.
You need to be able
to have the best
security possible for securing
all of the data that actually
exists, whether on
the BigQuery site,
or on a cloud storage site.
So cloud storage provides
you the bucket-level,
or the prefix-level
access control
that you can define and
set on these, policies
that you can set.
And BigQuery has
now added, I think,
we have added like column level
as well as rule level security
as part of BigQuery.
So customers can pick
and choose how they want,
and where they want
the data lake to be,
and what the data
lake storage is,
but these are the two common
choices that customers make
when they're picking a lake.
Now, when you look at how you
bring the data into the lake,
there are various
different services.
If you are bringing
data in real-time,
customers tend to
use [INAUDIBLE]..
And when you are looking to
move massive amounts of data
from your on prem
filers to GCP directly,
they end up using what we
call a transfer appliance.
Transfer appliances
are you can order them.
They will come to
your data centers.
You can copy it into
it, and ship it back,
and then it will be
copied into the buckets
that you have created
for this data.
Then you have data fusion
as another tool that
allows you to bring data, but
there are other capabilities
that exist within BigQuery
which are tied into BigQuery
from that perspective.
[INAUDIBLE] transfer
service that
allows you to
bring data from all
of the various different
[INAUDIBLE] sources
into BigQuery.
Now the data is being ingested
in, it needs to be cataloged.
So by default right
now, all of the data
that exists within
BigQuery automatically
gets registered
with data catalog.
But GCS, there is no
mechanism breakdown
by which the GCS data, the
data that gets stored on GCS,
gets cataloged automatically.
So you would have
to end up building
some kind of a
metadata extractor
that's looking at all
of the different buckets
and different files that
exist within GCS buckets,
and registering them
with the catalog.
So that's something
that you would have
to build by yourself right now.
So you would have to use your
favorite tool, programming
language of choice
to build and add
a crawling capability to add
metadata to the data catalog.
The other thing that
is required, in order
to make the data
accessible, is all
of the data that exists within
GCS bucket, so on the BigQuery.
So recent launched
Dataproc Metastore So this
is a high-compatible Metastore.
It's based on high Metastore.
So this will allow you
to register the data,
structured data specifically,
so that you can query it
using Spark, PRESTO, or Hive.
So this is another
system that basically
allows you to bring
more of metadata
and organize it in a
way that is for you.
Now, once the data is cataloged,
and once technical metadata
has been registered,
there are various tools
that are available on
GCP to actually process.
You have cloud Dataproc, which
is hosted Hadoop, managed
Hadoop, I would say.
And then you have
cloud dataflow,
which just provides you a server
list for a data processing
paradigm for code
batch, enter your time.
And then you have
BigQuery, which
has the query engine
that's part of it, that
allows you to run
analytics into your time
on the data that's
been ingested.
And then a lot of
machine learning
algorithms and techniques
that range, like, for example,
are automated.
That they can be pretty
much integrated--
are very much integrated
into BigQuery.
And there are also
approaches for connecting
with the data that sits on GCS.
Now, bringing in
all these together,
like when you look at it, there
are various different aspects,
right now, still exist.
That you would have to
spend a little bit more
time connecting them together.
First, you would have to
catalog all your data.
While the data in
BigQuery automatically
gets rendered in
data catalog, there
is some amount of
effort required
in cataloging all of the data
that exists within the cloud
storage system.
Now, when you think
about Metastore,
which is a new addition
to the Cloud GCP family,
it provides the much-awaited
technical metadata registration
for searching data that allows
the data to be now exposed
with the most popular open
source tools, which can, again,
be done on Dataproc.
So now let's look a
little bit further
into all of these really
just different technologies
or services that we have in GCP.
Let's start with storage first.
So how do people use GCS?
People consider GCS
as the data lake.
Some customers do that,
and then some customers
consider BigQuery
as the data lake.
And that's OK.
Both do have advantages
and disadvantages,
but they both can be
used as the base storage
layer for a data lake.
Most customers end up
bringing the data into GCP,
using various ingestion
tools and processing systems.
It's not just limited to
whatever GCP provides.
You could have
[INAUDIBLE] vendors
providing capabilities that
allow you to bring the data.
You can use any of
the SaaS services
to bring the data into GCP.
Now as you bring the data into
m the pattern that we observe
is, as the data goes through
various different forms
of processing, one of
the primary destinations
for this data that lands
on GCS is BigQuery.
And that's where most of the
analytics end up happening.
Because, as you guys
all know, BigQuery
is the data warehouse
offered by GCP.
Now when you look at it from a
BigQuery as a data warehouse,
data that gets
moved into BigQuery
is optimized for analytics from
the beginning, from the start.
As soon as you import
the data into BigQuery,
it's optimized for analytics.
Now, the way BigQuery
stores, the internal format
is very much
optimized in the sense
for doing a large-scale
analytics on data.
And we have customers who
stores petabytes of data,
and analyzed all of
that data in seconds.
Now, one of the differences
between BigQuery and GCS
is BigQuery, the data has to be
structured or semi-structured.
So you can store JSON and you
can store those kind of types
within BigQuery.
But on GCS, you can store any.
You can have images, you're
going to have audio files,
you can have pretty much
anything you want still
being stored on GCS.
Now let's go a
little bit further
and look at what are the
differences between these.
I want to be careful about
when we talk about cost.
I think the cost,
from a cost outlook,
it all depends on what
you do with the BigQuery,
but compared to
GCS, BigQuery now
has optimized with fixed
logs and all those things.
It basically gives you
a lot more optimization
from that perspective.
But the major difference that
exists between GCS and BigQuery
is the schema for BigQuery
has to be defined [INAUDIBLE]..
The schema has to be known.
But in GCS case, it
doesn't need to be.
They can actually
store just the files,
and they can define the
schema at that time.
The common data sources for all
of the data that exists in GCS
is like a file
format, any data type.
It doesn't matter if structured,
unstructured, semi-structured
data all can be stored.
Now, mostly BigQuery
is used from
a relational and
transactional databases,
but, as you can
imagine, there are also
semi-structured data that can
exist within the database.
For example like in Oracle.
They can be Excel,
they can be JSON.
So all of that, not
specifically Excel, but JSON
can be represented within
BigQuery seamlessly.
And the primary users,
when you look at it
from the perspective of these
two different services, cloud
storage data engineers, anyone
who can read and write a file
can basically access it.
In BigQuery, anyone who can
write a query, which are mostly
data analysts, business
analysts, even data
engineers, So pretty much
everyone on the planet
knows how to write a query.
So they can use BigQuery.
In that sense, the data is
a little bit structured,
and they would
have to understand
how to write a query, which
is really common these days
right now.
So anyone can do that.
The only difference
being is the data
is pretty much
structured in BigQuery,
and the data is not at
all structured in GCS.
Now what I mean it's
structured, it's
the representation of the
technical method of it.
Just like the columns,
and the types,
and those kind of things, not
the files and organization
of those files.
So these GCS and
BigQuery stories
becomes the foundation for any
data lake that you're building.
So depending on
your use cases, you
would have to make a choice.
Do you want to start with GCS?
Or do you want directly
land the data into BigQuery
and that becomes your
data lake storage?
Now, when you think
about it, in a few cases,
customers still want to
land the data in GCS,
and progressive to
GCS, and then load
only the data that isn't
required and curated
for analytics into BigQuery
for business analysis.
Now that we have looked
at storage options,
let's look at the catalog
and the metadata options.
The catalog in the metadata
options is the Metastore.
Now, as you guys all
know, data catalog
provides a central
catalog across GCP
for sorting all of the
metadata, indexing the metadata,
and making it much more
accessible to a search
interface,
So the interesting
part of all of this
is it also adds on
ability to create
some of the data governance
capabilities integrated
as part of that.
So you can use data
governance templates
to categorize various different
data assets within the catalog.
So right now, this is
very deeply integrated
from a BigQuery perspective,
but there is, in the future,
that there might be integration
automatically being provided
from a GCS perspective.
But in the meantime,
you would have
to have a system
that can analyze,
pick all of the metadata
that exists on GCS,
and populate that
into the data catalog.
So after tagging PII data.
So this is basically using
DLP, Data Loss Prevention--
it's yet another
service of GCP--
that allows you to
analyze the data
and identify any of
the sensitive data that
exists within that.
If there is any PII data,
and a lot of time that
PII data and surveys to the
administrators to act on
it once identified.
The data catalog also
provides the ability
where you have the
ability to control who
has access to what metadata.
Some of the parts--
as the data is important, the
metadata associated with that
also is very important.
So having ability to
provide how to have
access control over metadata
is a critical capability
that data catalog provides.
Now this is for all of
the metadata that exists.
And, as you all know,
there are three kinds up
metadata that exists--
technical, business and,
operational metadata.
So we're talking about
a business metadata,
and this is also incorporating
some of the technical metadata.
But this is not from the
viewpoint of processing.
This is just for making
the data accessible to you,
and making it easier to access.
Now, the next one
is more focusing
on how do you take technical
metadata and [INAUDIBLE] that
with the Metastore,
that then that allows
you to make it accessible.
Then that data becomes
accessible to open
source tools that exist
within the ecosystem.
So Dataproc Metastores is
a newly-launched service.
It's a fully-managed
highly-available open source
native, Apache Hive metastore
service which simplifies
technical metadata management.
All of the technical
metadata that exists
and that gets registered
within the Dataproc Metastore
is now accessible to Spark,
Hive, PRESTO, Notebooks.
All of these tools that
are popular in open source
already have ready access to the
data that exists in the lake.
Now, it's an alpha feature.
You should please go take it
for a spin, and give it a try.
And let us know if there
are things that you would
like to see improved on it.
But it's a great addition
to telling the true story
of a data lake on GCP.
Now, what does the
Dataproc Metastore provide?
It provides a
simplified management.
It allows you to create and
configure Dataproc Metastore.
It even comes out with
kerberos clusters,
so you can configure
a [? KDC ?] and do
all of those kind of stuff.
It provides the
[INAUDIBLE] capability.
And it's all integrated into
the standard console of GCP,
so you get a
fully-managed experience
for managing one or more
Metastores in your lake.
Now that we have talked about
the storage and the metadata,
we can look at the
other components that
exist within the lake,
critical components that
exist within the lake.
Now, data exploration analysis
is an important aspect of it.
Now, because we talked about
registering the metadata,
and with Dataproc Metastore,
you should be able to,
as soon as you
bring the data in,
you want to do some kind
of an exploratory analysis.
You should be able to use tools
like Hive to preview the data.
Now the data, because it
is registered with Hive,
you'll be able to query the
data using a Hive or Spark right
from the console.
Now, because of the launch
of Dataproc notebooks,
the notebooks are also
integrated with all
of this data, making exploratory
analysis much more easy
and fun.
So you don't have to
have a separate system.
You don't have to manage
it all by yourself.
It's all managed
within the Dataproc,
and makes it extremely
easy to get access
to all of the data that gets
registered with the Dataproc
Metastore.
Now, there is a little bit
of a manual process where
you would have to register for
the data that already exists
on GCS, and not register
with the Hive Metastore.
You would have to
do that manually,
like I have alluded
to that before.
But that's something
that, in the future,
we might basically
make it automatic.
But for right now, you will have
to write something that'll just
pull all of that stuff
and put it in metadata,
and put it in there.
Now what are the use
cases that I talked about?
So you want to have ability
to spread the data between,
for example, between
BigQuery and GCS.
Now, the interesting thing
is how do you figure out
what is between that?
So BigQuery has recently
launched the ability
to query the data
using federated tables.
So you can define that
as an external table
for data that's sitting on GCS.
And partly, part of the
data could be in BigQuery.
You can join.
You can do all normal operations
that you can do with the table,
can be done with
federated queries.
So here, it's a simple
process of [INAUDIBLE]..
Now wouldn't it be cool
if all of the data that
sits on GCS and any other
system automatically
gets registered into
Hive and gets represented
as an external
table in BigQuery,
so that any tool that
exists in the ecosystem
can use the metadata
that is being registered
to query the data, and make
it immediately accessible.
So the data lake doesn't have
to end up being a silo storage,
but making it much more
accessible to these ecosystem
tools that are
basically providing
that additional service to
form a registration of metadata
perspective.
So transformations.
We have talked about when
you build a lake, yes, you
want to have the ability
to transform your data.
You want the ability to do
complex transformations on it.
But we have never seen--
at least I have never
seen a simple job
that's running within the lake.
It's a complex
network of hundreds
of jobs that are
actually running
in the lake in many enterprises.
And in order to control all of
that, and manage all of that,
you need two things.
One, first of all, you need
the ability to run the job
to do the transformation.
So you can use Dataproc
or you can use Dataflow
to do that [INAUDIBLE].
So Dataflow is a [INAUDIBLE]
offering for [INAUDIBLE]
earlier time stream processing.
And Dataproc is basically
supporting both Hadoop
and Spark [INAUDIBLE].
Now, what do we
need to do for this
is to be able to take these two
things together and orchestrate
them using Cloud Composer.
So while I can
essentially create jobs,
I want to be able to stitch
them together in a bag,
and that can be
done with Composer.
In addition to this, you can,
of course, look at Data Fusion
as a way of doing
transformations.
But Data Fusion
underneath uses Dataproc
and provides a visual tool.
It's a data innovation tool.
It provides an ability to do
the similar stuff on top of it,
where you don't need to
have any programming.
You can do just do it
in a code-free manner,
So now that we have looked
at all of these things--
the storage, the metadata,
the transformation--
now the last thing
that is required
is the ability to bring
all of the data integration
aspects and the ability to look
at the lineage edge-to-end.
Because when you look at how the
data flows within data lake--
so while Dataflow and
Dataproc provides the advanced
transformation capabilities,
data integration
like Data Fusion provides much
more a manage-detailed solution
with no-code retail pipeline,
So you need to also
have ingestion template,
and ingestion template
for [INAUDIBLE]..
So you should be able to look
at as an example of BTU transfer
service, it provides
a very simple form
that allows you to look at--
select a source,
select a destination,
be able to just copy the
data over into the target.
So you need to have the
ability to do simple ingestion.
And the data lake should not
limit only for the usage of--
you should be able to
use any form of Google.
So we have customers
who use Informatica,
we have people use Talent.
People use [INAUDIBLE]
to bring the data in.
And then they basically ETL it.
Here you can use,
as an option, you
can use Data Fusion to do that.
You can you also use
Data Fusion for doing
additional transformations,
if you like,
and deploy them into the lake.
All the data that gets
generated, gets deployed back
into the lake, or it can be
pushed into the data warehouse.
Now, one of the important
things from a large enterprise
perspective is ability
to keep track of the data
as it flows to the system.
So you need to have a good
understanding of how the data
is flowing in your lake.
So you need to have
good lineage capability.
While this lineage capability
right now exists only
in Data Fusion,
in the future, we
will be looking at making that
available as part of the data
catalog.
And once it's there,
you will be able to look
at lineage across the
board, end-to-end,
from that perspective,
from a GCP perspective,
for any data that exists.
Now the only limitation
of the current lineage
is that if you use Data
Fusion, only then that lineage
will be present.
The lineage is
available at two levels.
One is at a data set
level, which tells you
what job process worked
on what data set,
and what are the resulting
data sets that were generated.
The second is be able to
look at the field level.
The field level will give you a
much more granular information
of how an individual
field was generated,
and what the various
different data sets
that were connected to it--
the template, the resulting
theme from those operations.
So these will provide from
a compliance or the ability.
It provides an
end-to-end solution
to have the best
possible data lake,
So now that we have looked
at various different aspects
of data lake--
so we have looked at what
are the different storage
mechanisms we have in the lake,
what are the different metadata
systems they have, what
are the various different
transformation systems
we have, and what do you
do from a data integration
business perspective.
So bringing it all together
right now is a task.
It's something that you
would have to do yourself.
But in the future,
we are providing
all these deeper integrations
with various services
to make the life of building
data lakes much more easier.
It should be very easy
for you to just take
all of these integrated set
of services, and build lakes.
Our goal is to make
it as fast as you can.
Right now it probably
takes weeks or months,
so we should be able to
reduce that down to--
with all these tool integrations
that end up happening,
it should come
down to a few days.
Now, to summarize, as we
found during the talk,
building data lakes
is extremely hard.
Now, GCP provides all of
the necessary services
to build the best data
lakes you can possibly have.
As you can also see,
all of the innovation
that is happening
within GCP to build
the best-integrated parts.
As an example,
BigQuery now integrates
with data that exists on GCS,
allowing you to federate data
across BigQuery and GCS.
In addition to completing
the story for data lake,
we are closing a lot
of different gaps.
Dataproc Metastore is
another SaaS service
that just got launched that
provides you the ability
to integrate metadata and make
it accessible more open source
tools.
And these are some of
the capability that
exists in GCP that you can
leverage to build the best
lake possible.
Give it a try.
Thank you so much.